Put in the effort!
If you want to make it as an entrepreneur
you got to put in the effort.
You need to work for it.
It’s not going to be easy.
You’re putting your blood, your sweat
your tears, everything you got
into making this business fly.
I recently posted a tweet
with a quote from Mark Cuban
and Mark Cuban is a hustler.
The guy works hard and his quote was that I shared
“There’s very little knowledge that can’t be obtained through effort.”
And I got a tweet back from Kingston4Live
who wrote, “Can you explain that to me.”
Here’s the thing.
As entrepreneurs a lot of us have limiting personal beliefs.
We think, “Because I don’t know this
I’m not going to have success.”
And Cuban’s point is whatever you don’t know
whatever you need to find out
if you are willing to put in the time and the effort
you can find an answer.
If you really want to get in to an industry
and you have no background in it, you can go in
you can have massive success but you got to work for it.
Anything you need to learn
you can learn if you put in the time
the effort, the patience
the hustle to figure out how to make it work.
So that’s his point.
You’re not going to have massive success
as a startup working 40 hours a week.
If you look at Cuban and how he got started
he had huge success in everything that he touched at the beginning
because he was the hardest working guy.
When he was starting off as an employee
he was still the hardest working employee.
When he started with his various businesses
he worked it harder than any of his competition.
Even though he had less knowledge getting into it
he became the most knowledgeable person about that business
and people flocked to him because customers
want to deal with experts
and he only got that knowledge because he put in the time
he put in the effort, he hustled
he needed to make this happen.
So you got to do the same with your business.
You have to commit to it
You’ve got to pour yourself into it.
You have to believe that what you’re doing is right
that it’s going to work out.
If you put enough heart, passion
energy, and effort into making it happen.
And it’s okay even if you’re starting part time
but do something every day to grow this thing, right?
The goal is that you don’t have to be a part time entrepreneur.
You can quit your job and do this full time
and make a huge income and have a huge impact
but it comes from doing something every single day
to move your business forward
even if it’s just a little bit
because as soon as you start giving up on that
as soon as you stop putting in the effort
your company dies.
You have to be the heartbeat of the business.
You’ve got to pour into it
put your full energy
put your full effort
love it
and you will have success with your company.
Believe.
I hope that helps shed a little light on that quote.
I love it and hopefully it inspires you guys too.
If you guys liked the video, thumbs-up below.
Love seeing those come in.
And I want to hear what you have to think.
Please leave a comment underneath.
I want to know what you’re thinking
you like the video
you have a question for you company let me know.
I’ll do a video response. Thank you guys
we’ll see you soon.